c'est vrai que je déplore que elisabeth
tessier
fasse croire que l'astrologie permet de
faire des prédictions je déplore cela
parce que c'est faux et parce que c'est
donner une fausse idée de l'astrologie
faire croire que l'on peut prévoir un
accident de voiture un divorce des
choses comme ça c'est absolument faux
quand on fait de l'astrologie
sérieusement et honnêtement comme je
sais le faire pour vous êtes en train de
dire que c'est pas honnête c'est ça bon
alors d'abord est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
honnête c'est presque enfin bon écoutez
vous permettez je vais vous ré presque
pire c'est sinon ça veut dire vous êtes
incompétente ah oui on allait jouer
contre la malhonnêteté la compétence
abbas était elle est toujours très
mesuré dans ses propos
j'ai décidé de pas m'énerver parce que
je considère que moi j'ai fait mes
preuves et vous non vous êtes une
dilettante dans l'astrologie pour vous
est une nouvelle venue vous avez le
temps de faire votre chemin
effectivement vous avez en plus forte
réduction qui étaient toutes fausses